then you're gonna feel a finger and some
pressure yep yep yeah well yeah go oh
there's your prostate Oh Movember is
this thing that helps raise money and
awareness for prostate cancer
Movember is a great organization we're
not growing mustaches we're doing one
better and it involves the finger what
stuff okay we are gonna get our
prostates examined by a medical
professional I'm grateful for the
opportunity to raise awareness for this
thing and if we can make some people
smile along the way that's great
prostate exam so prostate cancer is the
most commonly diagnosed cancer amongst
men in the United States approximately
14% of men will be diagnosed with
prostate cancer at some point in their
lifetime oh no my grandfather died from
colon cancer and something that could
potentially affect me it rarely occurs
in men under 50
oh I don't actively think about being
susceptible to cancer it's not in my
family I'm a young person who can take
on the world
testicular cancer is a cancer that the
Tri guys need to worry about because
testicular cancer is the most common
cancer amongst men age 20 to 40 I only
came in here for prostate I don't know
we're gonna be doing nut feeling - I
didn't know I had to worry about it
don't call it nuts you well that's what
it is that what it is yeah
oh but it's for a good mustache is a way
to get men have a conversation we made
it fun to talk about a very serious set
of issues why do you think men have such
a problem talking about health I think
it stems from masculinity this concept
of man up
I remember when I was growing up you
know he broke a finger you just kind of
threw some duct tape on it it's a
cultural thing it's getting past or
redefining what it means to be a man if
it takes just one finger up the butt to
find out a life-or-death situation take
the whole hand up my butt we're gonna
have to trust this doctor to take care
of us take a real quick should we do the
testicular exam first or go straight for
the gold we'll do both of them at the
same time what it's like a sequentially
yeah
Oh No so we're gonna do the Genesee urn
exam and examine your testicles to see
if there is any abnormality okay already
not yeah okay I think it's a good idea
starting at about age 20 to age 42 do a
self-exam every month
you hear that you tube touch them nuts
the testicular exam was nothing he just
felt the top of the ball which I didn't
realize there was a top of the ball and
the left one feels just fine we need to
call just a stranger touching your nuts
as does the right one great nice so
let's move on to the digital rectal exam
never had anything up my butt well man
that are aged 25 to 40 have to get the
nuts felt and then that are age 50 or
older have to get their butts booked
that's basically right yep oh so 40 to
50 those are the golden years I on your
side with your right side down bring
your knees up a bit to expose your
bottom okay bottom exposed don't some
people bend over yeah that can be done
also you can just stand up and lean over
and put your elbows on the tape has
anyone done like missionary style the
doctor had us lay on our sides
Eugene of course bent over because he's
Eugene I think it goes deeper when you
do doggy style and he poured a ton of
Lube on that finger there wasn't
anything sexual when he's a doctor he
pressed his finger up against my
delightful anus Oh pressure and then
just went wow who's in the butt oh my
god oh my god and then he said okay
we're going and then boom and it's nice
and smooth great he just plunged his
finger deep inside my rectum he was
he'll neat and everything feels fine
normal smooth so that was efficient
super quick Oh very painless
well that was way deeper than I expected
lubed up in and out and do you feel fine
alright okay and here's some tissue if
you need it what do you say after you're
penetrated by a handsome man
I just had a finger up my butt well you
did a great job
oh no this was actually a really
educational day I know what I'm getting
myself into and it's really it's not
that bad
it's super harmless it's super painless
compared to what women go through
scraping the vagina with metal stuff
every year cancer is not something you
think about but then when you go in to
get checked for cancer it's it's really
scary that was a lot of talking about
cancer all at once does that ever get
difficult of course it gets difficult
taking care of patients who have serious
illness but we do a good job sometimes
and these patients can live quite some
time and sometimes are even cured of
their disease best thing for people to
do in terms of getting involved is go to
member comm signup get engaged to
understand what we're trying to do in
the world have a conversation with your
friends and family and get a team
started Rachel oh I'm ready to go into
the shower and constantly feel my balls
but if you can just grow the mustache
for Elmo and save a bro I want to thank
dr. ed egg and the UCLA Johnson
Comprehensive Cancer Center I'm grateful
that we had the opportunity to spread
awareness a spread of cheeks
can we go one more lube for YouTube
there it is
nice job guys